[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils espèrent que si vous voulez mieux, ils disent
ici la Bastille une fête après ne pas
gagner vous voyez une base Wagga perdre pour l'
échec de l'agent SWAT oh peut-être a été touché
par des rochers sur la Jeep
[Musique] les
autres sont d'accord pour nous perdre sans ambages saluer
les cours de personnes aa sont tous réglés dans mon ils
[Musique]
ne dites pas une tante exhaustive incessante
les poches sont ma fille G disparu
[Musique]
Asuna regarde les chefs de père falafel vous
soufflant à plat Gina un très habituel
vas-tu maximiser la nourriture
[Musique]
ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]